welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is the breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 8 chapter
16 the season finale titled the rescue
a big spoiler warning before i continue
because we have just had
our 2020s rescued by the return of
luke skywalker jedi master carve and
dark troopers like christmas turkeys but
is it a true rescue because
this dude's future school is gonna get
massacred and torched by his nephew
don't go grogo yes much of this finale
episode was pure fan service but
from its alderaan referencing opening to
its king boba post credit scene there
are a ton of missable details orabesh to
translate
specifically chosen fight choreography
music deeper layers of meaning that you
might not have thought about so i'm
gonna break it all down
shot by shot you're gonna love this one
okay the slave one is in hot pursuit of
dr pershing's
land class shuttle this is reserved for
vips of the empire but they disable it
with an ion cannon
this is what they use to escape hoth and
the empire strikes back and then they
bore the ship lower your shields
disengage your transponders
prepare for boarding yeah the tension
here reminds me of the fear of the crew
of the tantive iv
when they were being disabled and
boarded by darth vader think about it
this whole episode opens and closes with
echoes of vader just like this
and then the meaner of the two imperial
pilot joe dabney courtney from agents of
shield confirms dr pershing's role for
us
to me this is a top-tier target of the
new republic this is a clone
engineer yeah we knew he was a clone
engineer from those camino patches but i
find it interesting that he's a major
target of the new republic
suggesting that they might know cloners
are working for remnants of the empire
or
maybe that the new republic has some
genetic experience of their own going on
the pilot points out the tear tattoo on
carradoon's cheek which marks her as an
alderaanian survivor and he says that i
had friends on the death star
and that alderaan's destruction was
worth it it has been very
interesting to see alderaan come up so
much this season in terms of the
psychological effect it's had on both
sides of this conflict we will go deeper
into that question in our final episode
of wikileaks coming out next week
these industrial smokestacks have the
symbol of the pre-empire republic on
them which is interesting suggesting
they might have resisted imperial
influence
the slave one lands beside this ship
this is boca tan ship
the gauntlet saw that in clone wars
final season looks so cool you can also
barely make out some astro
droid rolling on the landing yard i
always say that because whenever i see
one of those i'm like is it r2 no it's
not r2 but then this episode or two dip
show up at the end now in this diner are
some familiar races there's some
aqualicious there's a rhodium
and what looks like a jar of spatuka on
the bar there with bokutan and costco
reeves at the far table
coming back from chapter 11. now where
was axe woves
i assume he's just in the toilet and was
very confused to come back and find
everybody gone
i'm not paying for this but before i
continue thanks to sit with me bessie's
shoes for sponsoring this video
you know i love these things desi shoes
reflect water and snow like
best scar steel to flex storm trooper
shots if any of them have good enough
aim
bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof and weatherproof and
way more comfortable than some stiff old
winter boots beaded boots besties shoes
are super
stretchy they fit like a sock they only
weigh 175 grams
and they're made with this space-age
dynamics material so these shoes you can
wear every day in all kinds of weather
you can leave them by the door and have
one less thing to worry about they are
easy to clean with just a rinse of water
or just toss them in the washing machine
another thing you can't do with boots
damn boots bessies are sustainably made
with no animal byproducts
whether i'm stomping through puddles or
just diving deep on some mandalorian
easter eggs besties keep my feet dry and
comfy
oh i'm so sad that there's no more
mandalorian episodes this season to
break down
i've been crying all over my shoes but
luckily thanks to these messy knit
sneakers
my tear juice isn't getting my toesy
woozies anyway
thanks bessie yay click on the link
below
and use my code new rockstars do get 25
off oh but look at that there's a menu
board in oremesh
merry christmas here's what's for dinner
starting on the left column and working
our way down we got
kadu ribs kaju are the creatures that
the gungans ride on naboo
yum and then there's gornt going to say
meat from the omnivorous beast from
hithar
often referenced in insults and jokes in
legends material like wedge antilles
once started a joke saying so there's a
bothan who walked into a tap cap with a
gornt under his arm
then there's roast noona jabba the hutt
was eating some nuna and venom minutes
really playing with this food nuna are
the swamp turkeys of naboo you can
actually see them on the menu at batu
and disneyland's galaxy's edge there's a
kind of stew and then there's indorian
tip yip
which is actually a fried dish that you
can also get a galaxy's edge
the tip yip of endor and disneyland is
just kind of like fried chicken on a bed
of
veggies then there's shock kebab made
from the
fat ass shot tick looking mammals that
anakin surfed on naboo before almost
dying and then there's
jorgen and topato topeto and a grip for
a potato
mashem stick him in a stew is a root
veggie our old diner friend dexter
jetstar uses topeto slices on his
coruscant slider then there's yoba
shrimp yoba shows up in the legends
legacy of the force invincible book
space waffles okay actually space
waffles is a food that has appeared in
rebels and clone wars they love it and
then we move to the top of the right
column
this ice and mailering juice which is
another legend's fruit that has shown up
in rebel hero loves these things
again you can buy this juice at galaxy's
edge i want to go to there then roasted
cd
and then haroun bread along with lambta
and
arisa these were served on schnees table
when qui-gon jar jar and padme
stayed with them in phantom menace and
then kushnip with fral
which is a dish served at maz kanata's
place in the force awakens
and then poly starch that's that awesome
muffin-y looking bread that
rey makes on jakku an effect done
practically and
universe is actually a gross military
ration i don't know why anyone would
want to order this at a diner and the
same goes for the veg
meat which is a ration protein that was
also in the force awakens visual
dictionary
it might be why these two appear at the
end of the menu they're kind of cheap
crap for anyone with limited credits so
that covers this menu but if you are
wondering what this means
all of that isn't the quakta calling the
stiffling slimy
and no out there quacta and stifling are
new terms that we'll probably get
trading cards sometime soon then koska
also mentions a back to tank
that's the healing tank we have seen
vader in luke swimming around in boca
tan and koska do not get off on a good
foot with boba fett
you are a disgrace to your armor the
sama belonged to my father
don't you mean your donor careful
princess you are a clone
i've heard your voice thousands of times
boba calls boca tan princess
it's not just an insult it's a nod to
her actual royal lineage
and previous ownership of the dark saber
and presumably humiliating defeat at the
hands of maf gideon
and yeah bobo would have the same voice
as every other clone that botan met
during the clone wars
and also you'll notice her eye line gets
a perfect look at his sigil
on his repainted armor this is a nod to
jasper muriel mentor to his father
donor django and their clan the true
mandalorians who were long time enemies
to the death watch which was bocatan's
previous clan
before she left the death watch to start
her own night owls really it's that boba
fett
wrote off mandalore as a lost cause that
pissed her off so much he said that the
empire turned it into glass
as in they lasered it so hard the sand
melted in the glass
so they team up and they form a plan
with dr pershing
now on their side remember he did want
grogu to be kept alive explaining why he
might be more eager to help with her
plan
he explains that the dark troopers have
this two-minute window as they charge up
and that they are the third
generation not to them being phase three
dark troopers from that dark forces game
their approach plan is pretty clever
they use the slave one to pretend
they're in distress
and then they use that land of class
shuttle to block the launch tube so that
no further thai fighters could exit and
i love boca tan's initial assist here
she ropes a storm trooper and then sets
him up for koska to
jet knee into him teamwork and this
leads to a true girls get it done raid
sorry axe wolves those space waffles
were how much
now a little detail that i appreciated
when they knocked that stormtrooper off
the walkway
threw that shield into open space his
speed kind of flatlines constant the
moment he falls through that barrier as
opposed to like a normal accelerating
drop which makes sense you would move at
the constant velocity that you were
traveling at the moment
you cross through that barrier and then
your speed is just kind of constant from
there forward
then we pass what looks like an ra7
droid like the one we saw in the jawas
sand crawler in the first movie and as
mando tries to bottle up those dark
troopers one
claws his hands out the doors similar to
the t-1000 that he does to the elevator
doors the t2 judgement day and i say
that because these things are super
terminatory he just keeps
punching mando's head into the wall
though i love how mando's helmet doesn't
give it just
smushes deeper into the bulkhead mando
stabs that dark trooper with his best
guard spear and he finds grogu with moff
assume that i know everything a very
important line because think about it
mock gideon knows that bo katan is with
him he actually heard her voice over the
com earlier
we are under attack and he saw her
arriving on the feed
probably recognizing her night owl paint
on her armor and he knows that she
is here for the dark saber so mando now
telling gideon that he doesn't care
about that dark saber
is a potentially critical error for
mando because it tells gideon that he
should engage mando anyway because even
if he loses
mando winning and being able to claim
that darksaber totally screws over bo
katan
it'll create a point of contention
between the two because it has deprived
her of her chance
to truly claim her saver back and by the
way this whole elder wand succession
rule seems to be a bit
new because when boca tan first received
that dark saber in rebels she did not
win it in combat sabine wren just found
it in maul's cave and then handed it to
her but as we discussed in wikileaks and
we will go into further next week
i think bogatan's need to win comes from
her own stinging defeat
she lost it to moff gideon and by
winning it from her he proved himself
worthier than her when she was just kind
of given it
so in order to reclaim it and win back
the respect of the mandalorian people
she has let down
she must claim it with flute and that's
why the rule is so important to her as
manu and gideon fight notice how the
dark saber doesn't
cut the best scar spear but it does heat
it up to a nice
warm orange glow almost enough it looks
like to melt
it now we did not see it get to that
point when ahsoka was fighting morgan
lightsaber versus best guard spear
i think that is because the darksaber's
unique design
notice as gideon turns it we briefly
just see it as pure white we only see
its edge it's flatter most lightsabers
are pull-shaped they have this
cylindrical beam of plasma
but the darksaber is a flattened sharper
sword with a finer edge
capable of wedging into the best scar
less likely to slide up and down it
so they end up holding up in the bridge
as the dark troopers are returning but
then this happens
next wing one x-wing great
we're saved yes notice grogu's ears
perking up
telling us that this is the jedi that he
pinged from that python scene stone
and yeah whenever there's just one
solitary x-wing
we know it is our man luke skywalker and
clearly the production team of the show
knows that it's going to be awkward to
see his dh
face so they do this smart thing of
preceding his reveal by
showing him as a hooded badass look at
him go
actually there's this little detail
where he uses a behind the back
deflection
just like his father anakin did to that
battle droid on mustafar and revenge of
the sith
and as he realizes who this is fear
fills gideon's eyes
and he kind of goes nuts with that
blaster he tries to take out grogu this
does echo werner herzog's client
character being willing to take that
child dead or alive
both of them know the worst thing is for
jedi master luke skywalker to get his
hands on this child from the yoda
species
and fearing what this means for himself
he even tries to take his own life holy
[ __ ]
luke's death march continues into this
final tunnel where the imagery matches
the kill box that his father
vader created with the rebel soldiers in
rogue one and this includes everything
violent lightsaber slashes force pushes
force pulls sparks are flying
and it ends with this awesome force
crush it's not a common move used by the
jedi though and the animated clone wars
movie mace windu used it on grievous
which is what caused grievous to have
his sad breathing issues
and then luke enters the bridge and
reveals his face
notice how his hand is covered in a
glove because of course it was severed
and actually we hear the music of john
williams force theme the binary sunset
[Music]
so yes they dh mark hamill they use the
same process of these with carrie fisher
in rogue one they started with a
stand-in actor with similar facial
structure in this case with luke it was
max lloyd jones and then they digitally
mapped hamill's younger face from
archived footage
over it and then did their best to match
the motion of his facial expressions and
his mouth movement now it is not totally
clean especially when he talks just
because it is nearly impossible for
animators to try to replicate the way
the mouth in the jaw
folds and wrinkles to make it fully
lifelike there's just lots of different
skin surfaces
it's hard to animate that out of the
uncanny valley luke says this
interesting line
but talent without training is nothing
which i gotta say sounds a bit like a
meta call out
too oh i don't know the way rey was
written to be an
immediate jedi badass based on natural
talent with hardly any training but as
mando removes his helmet so grosgu can
see his face for the first time
definitely echoing the moment luke
unmasked vader for the first time
allowing vader to gaze upon his son
figure with his own eyes
notice the music
yes we are back to that sweet heartfelt
wondrous music
that played over grogu connecting with
his future snack food back in chapter
10. clearly this is the music of groku's
childlike wonder fascination and feeling
of
home and as we are crying mando tells
him
don't be afraid which is perfect because
it isn't just reassurance it is advice
to resist the child's fear of losing
personal attachments like this
something ahsoka warned him about sense
much fear in you
and we know that fear is what class the
path of the dark side
but luke of course ain't the only cameo
r2 he shakes with excitement upon seeing
grogu which could be a signal that r2
might recognize this species and might
remember
yoda or the possibility that r2 could
have been the one who saved grogu from
the jedi temple
i'll explore that in another video and
we get this post-credits scene
showing boba fett and fenix shan taking
jabba's palace now ruled by a chubby
chubby bib fortuna he was formerly
java's right-hand man and all this is
very reminiscent of act one of return of
the jedi
we see all of his old cronies and
buddies actually that backup dancer is
ristal sant
returning from returning the jedi great
attention to detail and i love how we
see their shadows as they're coming down
the steps just as they saw luke's shadow
coming down those steps
but the detail i love the word bib
fortuna says pizza
mcclunky oh boy you know this one this
was added in as the final words of
greedo when a new hope appeared on
disney plus
but this wasn't just a random thing this
was actually confirmed to translate to
this will be the end of you and it was
spoken by sababa to jar jar back in
phantom menace
and as boba sits atop his throne fenix
swigs some spatuka
at his side the book of boba fett is
coming december 2021
some are saying this could just be the
subtitle of the mandalorian third season
i actually think it's just gonna be a
whole other spin-off limited series now
i go much deeper into where
grogu is headed next with luke whether
he is one of the victims of kylo ren
and whether he will ever return to this
series and what form that we'll take
he will he's probably gonna be a silent
teenager taking a bow of silence
all in the recent episode wikileaks
definitely go check that out it's a
great episode also a reminder to get
your limited edition this is the way
shirt exclusive from new rockstars
official merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com we've been selling
out of this fast we might still have a
few more red and white varieties
surprisingly to us lots of random people
have been buying these shirts from just
outside our channel but they don't
really know the significance of it being
a collectible limited run item latest
obsession
we want to make sure true watchers of
this channel can get priority for it so
we are gonna give
you guys a coupon in our diehards to try
to make sure the last of the shirts go
to the true fans
again newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars on youtube hit that
notification bell
we have lots more star wars theories to
break down the coming weeks thank you
for watching this season i have spoken
[Music]
you